[Music]
and not professional news submitted by
dreams and nightmares a homeowner is
furious with Detroit firefighters after
they took a selfie with his burning
house oh that's [ __ ]
hey you are they smiling are they
putting it out though while they're
taking the pie no I hope so it's making
the house look like there was their dig
did they smile or were they like sad
that's a big one I would be pissed if I
see houses are burning every day I would
prefer it nonsense a fire fire in a
bikini easy is it for the calendar I'm
thinking of all the other houses out
there that are burning if you like super
in the front and then pretend like he's
gonna step on the house that's good or
no he's putting his hands up like he's a
sorcerer thank you all right so this
photo it was posted on Facebook and it
was just before midnight on New Year's
Eve and it was captioned with cruise
take a moment to get a selfie on New
Year's on New Year's and then it was
posted to the Facebook page Detroit fire
incidents page so is it then be like
while you're celebrating New Year's
we're putting out fires oh cool that's
like the NFL when they scored touched a
class photo that's so bad cuz I was just
thinking it's one guy and I'm like
sensitize he knows like it's not that
big but this stick [ __ ] Corral
everyone hey guys are you busy look at
the photographer's like a crazy one
everyone funny one no it's blinking so
you know this wasn't the first one they
took pissed that's a pretty shitty house
you know oh my god it's like Victorian
style with someone living in there was
it empty you can see them right there
I'm kidding I'm kidding Detroit that
house could be 30 grand
free we're talking about moving to
Detroit last night yeah well I mean we
just saw really cheap houses and were
like you could move in you could move
into a home there for free all you got
to do is pay the [ __ ] bill like a tax
bill and Emma sold his childhood home
for a dollar what and you didn't get it
right it was the oh yeah I didn't get it
they burned down a house in eight mile
it started at a dollar yeah they did
Yeah right
so what's the difference between that
and this well because the firefighters
whose job is that only daddy looks like
beyond repair like it's only like pocket
it's too late look at the bottom floor
you don't put it out they could go to
another house so they were mad that they
were just taking a photo instead of
saving them sort of horrified cuz that
to me looks like a house that's already
gone no well maybe at this point it's
like might as well make the best out of
it it's a good like to corral my dad so
cheap he'd be like the roof is mostly
good actually it's closed thing dude my
aunt lived in a place where the fire
burned down their roof and they just put
an American flag over it getting shut
down by the city a year later but a year
yeah she lived there for a year so it
was like a flag when you kind of see the
debt that yeah yeah yeah like when
you're on the inside the flag is
covering this huge hall in that like the
whole roof is like burned off but like
that just goes to show how much it rains
here in LA like it never [ __ ] rains
how strong the American flag is it had
been in this guy's family for 50 years
like his grandma was really sick so they
had moved her out in in them and during
that time that they had moved her out is
so they could remodel the home so it
could be good enough for her to live
there probably built in 1920 election
fire then because the plugs back then
the outlets weren't very good true yeah
there's we don't see what started it but
all the [ __ ] [ __ ] places
no no Detroit's coming up Marshall
person others the third lives in Detroit
I'm fine I haven't been in a long time I
heard that it is doing better but coming
I've never seen a city where half of the
skyscrapers were boarded up with plywood
true it's it's for the movie world world
look like some Batman [ __ ] yeah it's for
the movie world
why'd you have to say that fine it's not
a movie world you mean the movie okay
the one okay I know again yeah I wanted
them to be scared that we're thinking
about moving to Detroit for her to be
scared yes I was pretty scared but thank
you thanks outskirts of Detroit okay
they have really nice places we worked a
lot among people yep
friendly Hmong people do we have to be
Lions fans no okay oh thanks we're just
gonna live in sure wow you have a really
cool McDonald's if they had a McDonald's
there where the back of it had nice like
lazy boy chairs and my friend cried at
that big God because he joined us on the
trip because he thought that is why I
was gonna divorce him and she did
that's a good reason to cry I thought he
was just crying cause he's in the
McDonald's away but now he's good no
because he's all divorce it son yeah
yeah he's good now he's the funny thing
is it's it's okay well it's hard to feel
bad that it suffered and a lazy boy
never tanto it's out of context the
funny thing is that they got a divorce
apparently this guy picked the worst
time to give you the most devastating
news of his life so they were this was
their first show ever many he drops that
on them and then his first stand-up show
ever he cries again right before he's
supposed to go up and I was like I'm
gonna do this right now this is Bart's
moment you need to save this [ __ ] what
was your client dinner I remember he was
crying I'm just trying to go through the
midst yeah no I think she left at that
point yeah and I'm like you're not
[ __ ] doing this the bar right now
this is this moment we'll talk about
this [ __ ] later first show the first
stand-up show that me and bar was doing
in Detroit he wasn't even supposed to go
so it was just me and Bart and he joined
paid his own ticket to come with us and
then at the last minute we're like about
to do the show we're trying to get some
food like we're like hungry we're like
nervous and he just starts crying in the
back of a very nice McDonald's nice
chair a nice McDonald look very nice
yeah like basically nice massage guy to
is all jokes like like if you see this
guy he doesn't say anything serious he's
always talking about dick ass fart jokes
and that's why it's even it hits even
harder wardrobes too huh it's really bad
but like you wanna bang my daughter when
she's 18 and the daughter is like four
years old yeah yeah he's crazy he's
absolutely yeah huhuhuh she'll sit on
people's motorcycles and ask him how
much and then they'll be like three
thousand dollars and you'll be like how
about I suck your dick and you paint you
I give you half the money like you'll
say sir no sir you'll say crazy [ __ ]
okay anyways so to put in context what a
potty mouth he is and he's very
unemotional we're eating at McDonald's
and he goes literally he goes like that
guys crying the best Amy and Bart are
staring at each other like what the [ __ ]
what's going on how do we even deal with
this because this is
we were even more colder as people so
we're just looking at that kids right
[Laughter]
maybe we don't know it but they won on
the first date time ago you're more
emotionally intelligent you can fight
and you just like holding onto the by
looking at other like what's what [ __ ]
do we do the funny part about this guy
is that he's the type of guy that's like
that me and my wife we just got in a
fight where I [ __ ] go home I'm a pack
of [ __ ] bags throw it out in the
front and try to get the holiday that's
wife even funnier yeah I wonder why you
got a divorce don't be smoking on my
weight doesn't doesn't your wife not
like when you smoke I do have a [ __ ] I
want this [ __ ] listens to me and as
soon as we get pull up into his driveway
he'll literally talk his [ __ ] pulling up
[Applause]
yeah I have to channel some of that in
the character because he's such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] talker and he talked so
much [ __ ] [ __ ] like what a badass you
think I'm a teller [ __ ] everything
when she gets home and he's like hi
honey did you need help do you need
we're watching
cause hi honey would you like to [ __ ]
him again he's so soft and gentle to his
wife at the time and then he talks all
this [ __ ] [ __ ] and that's why it's so
funny because the contrast behind this
[ __ ] is like so good he's up here talk
he talks so much [ __ ] [ __ ] and to see
him fall I think I love that [ __ ] it's
so funny was that you know how everyone
in the photo is surrounding this one guy
in a yellow jacket yes was it his
retirement yeah so it turns out that he
was his retirement and that's the reason
why they took a photo but one last part
in house the Deputy Fire Commissioner
said that it was taken this photo was
taken outside of vinca of a vacant home
so there were no victims or anything um
and I thought he burned his own house
down wait so gram so once they posted
its on Facebook people were so upset
because they were like like I hope this
is a staged fight well first of all they
were saying like well Happy New Year's
you guys are the fast pull the LA and
then other people were like what the
hell I hope that was a staged fire like
I wouldn't want I hate to think my
firemen were posing for photos while a
real house is burning and it's like this
uh they're like way to look professional
this really puts about a wrap on your
company too great computer graphics yeah
so then they're just say so the people
from the fire department we're like what
we're investigating this this is highly
inappropriate there are other ways to
celebrate a retirement but taking a
photo in front of a burning fire that
you're responsible for taking this fire
like that's how the most epic pictures
yeah [ __ ] that biggest [ __ ] you guys
should get married
you're a match you guys really have some
corner looking like nothing nothing
they spent the whole time taking
pictures what they have a barbecue I
probably need to figure out the camera
cuz they're white the the side like what
is that the wall foundation with the
fence what did you think so hey just
water the port's Tanith oh this you mean
I didn't get charged yeah that's what
company did that we they saved that
fence yeah
what no something we're saying that they
were just focusing on like the fire not
spreading to other structures cuz it was
already gone did they at least say
because we couldn't salvage it at that
point I would hope yeah that's what they
were saying but then there were
neighbors like witnesses that like nah
bro that [ __ ] was like this big of a
flame you could have saved it you kept
blowing on the fire to make it bigger
they're like we need on the fire look
bigger for this picture he's retiring
last one yeah big bait like no I was not
big enough yet they were saying that
they were barely even watering the like
putting water on it or even trying to
save it they were just like focusing on
this around yeah I don't feel like they
let it burn on purpose that's a witness
it's a killer photo that way GL go and
he it could have been just a little
sparking the window nobody would have
cared
[Music]